the loud houses lori and bobby are the
epitome of young love
this calls for musica but try telling
that to
lincoln and ronnie anne who are over
their siblings relationship and they're
not the only ones
bobby and laurie broke up awfully fast
what really caused their split and
is it a sign they should stay apart come
on guys
you'll have fun together i know it
bobby has always been so over the top
devoted to lori that he makes edward and
bella from twilight
look like just a couple of really good
friends it's no secret that their
relationship is sickeningly sweet
just ask their siblings don't get my bad
side bobby
you don't have a bad side babe so we
can't blame fans for being stunned when
they broke up in the episode
save the date and even more surprising
was the fact that bobby was the one who
dumped
lori what could have caused this couple
to break up
it was all lincoln's fault or at least
that's how laurie saw it
you monster oh what was that for
you made ronnie and cry in an effort to
disguise his own feelings for his
classmate ronnie anne
lincoln went on a rant about how he
would never want her as a girlfriend
which of course she overheard ronnie
anne was devastated and when she
confided in her big brother
he cut off his connection to the entire
loud family
because bobby is literally ronnie ann's
brother
according to lori bobby just couldn't
cope with the fact that her brother made
his sister cry
and felt like he had to end their
relationship desperate to win back bobby
laurie demanded lincoln accompany them
on a double date and make nice with
ronnie for her sake
it was pretty clear right away that
these two missed each other
intensely in what must have been hours
since they broke up
hi bobby hey babe i mean
lori naturally lincoln and ronnie bonded
over making fun of their siblings while
bobby described his time apart from lori
as torture these two are really dramatic
they got back together to the surprise
of no one but it makes you wonder why
bobby was so quick to dump laurie in the
first place
after all she didn't make ronnie cry so
why punish his soul mate for what
lincoln did
bobby may not be the brightest guy in
the world but we know he's intensely
loyal towards people in his inner circle
he wouldn't even buy lori flowers
because he thought store-bought was too
impersonal
so he went for a hand-picked which would
have been sweet if he knew the
difference between flowers
and poison ivy laurie swelled up like a
salted turkey
it's possible that he didn't think his
plan through and simply saw his sister
in pain
and reacted on his big brother instinct
to fix it even though that meant losing
his beloved girlfriend
to some people family comes first and
this could be why it seemed so
easy for bobby to break up with lori but
then again
bobby's plan to break up with lori did
result in ronnie and lincoln bonding and
becoming closer
so maybe he's a lot smarter than we give
him credit for
but probably not all right dude ready to
hit the
roller coaster ronnie and lincoln may
have been left
nauseated by their siblings but lori and
bobby seemed perfectly happy bonding
over selfies and shared pet names
so what's the problem some fans think
these two have crossed the line
into codependence oh boo-boo bear i
can't wait for her anniversary date this
friday
after all it doesn't really seem like
the two of them have that much in common
besides their obsessions with each other
we've seen bobby do a lot for lori
but how much of that is reciprocal it
seems like she's the one giving commands
and he just goes with the flow thanks to
his laid back nature
he's also forgiving to a fault as we saw
in cheater by the dozen
when everyone thought he was cheating on
lorry underneath that flawless hair and
those washboard abs
beats the cold heart of a liar for the
purposes of the show
their relationship is usually played off
as a joke about how infatuated they are
with each other
are these two just going through an
extended honeymoon period or do they
really have what it takes to make a
lasting relationship
sure it's possible they both met their
soul mate really early in life
and they'll be together forever but how
long before bobby decides he doesn't
want to be called booboo bear
and how would lori react to that because
we have a feeling it
might involve her throwing things some
couples are able to grow and mature
together but it might be better for
bobby
laurie and us watching at home to see
them gain
independence before they sign up for a
lifetime of sharing selfies
or maybe we're just a little bit jealous
of bobby's devotion babe i would drive
to the moon for you
yeah it's probably that what do you
think about the relationship between
these two loud house characters
do you love them as a couple or do you
want to see them end things for good
this time
share your thoughts with us and your
fellow fans in the comment section below
and stay connected with us here at the
things by clicking on the subscribe
button and turning on your notifications
thanks for watching and we'll see you
again next time
[Music]
you